sunday afternoon fourth and final game
in this four game set against the
baltimore oreos pacquiao's have won two
of the
three games so far in this series 12th
start of the season
for stripling he's looking to win his
third game of the season last time out
he couldn't pitch much better against
miami
brian castle is next seven home runs in
the month of june most by
orioles rookie since nick marquez had
ten back
oh now castle out to left field
and this ball is out of here
ryan meltcastle wins the long battle
against stripling
and puts the orioles on top one to
nothing
as he continues to increase his
candidacy
for al rookie of the month in june
there's another shot up the middle but
the defense is set up perfectly
as physio throws to first there are
the numbers for jorge no first start
against toronto
three two pitch there's a liner up the
middle for a base headed bo bushet gets
his day off to a good start
now once hit on the ground to short uras
to second one
off to first it's a double play
okay oscar at 298 for the season home
runs
11 47 driven in
there's a line drive in the right field
that's going to be
on the hop
well the first three reach here in the
second inning a single and back-to-back
walks and lopez is having trouble
throwing strikes
nobody out bases loaded 0-2 pitch
ground ball toward short second for one
back to first double play
but a run comes in and the blue jays
have
tied it so they'll have a look at the
pivot at second base
looked like lama's right foot may have
drug across the back watch his right
foot
as he's going to step into the throw it
looks like he drags it over the top of
second base
and i think that's enough right there to
give him the double plays
the umpires have their ruling and
they uphold the call breaking ball
popped him up
should do it mckenna drips into left
center makes the catch
and that's it for the second inning
[Applause]
rips the first pitch into left field for
a base hit
not wasting any time another first pitch
base hit for the blue jays
we'll try away floats it into right
catch made by hayes and so both runners
will stay in place
but now you did all that work and you've
got to face
vlad guerrero jr with two men on this
and beshets it back was
nine pitches before he lined out to
right field so guerrero has
a lot of insight as to what lopez is
featuring
fair ball down in that field line that's
going to score one for sure
simeon is coming around he's being waved
home here's the throw to the point no
throws it's cut off
and guerrero comes through once again a
two-strike one out two-run double for
vladi and the blue jays have a 3-1
lead blew the fastball by him at 96.
kevin bishop walks his only time up goes
after the first pitch and rips at the
lafia
they're going to send the runner and if
it's a good throw he'd call him
safe austin wins had i tagged him laddie
guerrero with a nifty slide
the orioles are probably going to
challenge it so
this is what they'll look at
i think he got the top of the hand joe
west will make the call
[Applause]
off the end of the bat out to shallow
right
and this one falls in front of biggio
simeon overruns it it's a base knock for
franco
first pitch swinging gives the orioles
their second hit ramona
is up to the plate for the orioles
breaking ball
this is walloped out to center and it'll
get past
grichik and roll onto the warning track
they're sending
franco around relay throw to bushette
it's coming
in franco evades the tag and the orioles
pull within
a run on the rbi double by urease
[Applause]
hit on the ground to third fair ball
panic
has no play and so everybody's
corey got safe looking for something
else right there stripping crossed him
up and through a fastball right now on
broadway strike three call
[Applause]
there's a one heart but his short stop
they force out the runner and second
metal in the inning
guerrero leads the majors in home runs
[Applause]
or what a rocket over the head of the
left fielder dj stewart it's hit so hard
guerrero will have to settle for a loud
single one-on-one sue hernandez
[Applause]
there's another ball ripped down the
left field line
guerrero is headed around second he'll
go to third tie oscar
goes into second the ball gets away but
that'll be yet another hard hit ball for
the blue jays kevin bisgio got to base
hit on the first pitch his last time up
so in two with two outs runners at
second and third abujs
have a one-run lead
breaking ball lifted into the air d.j
stewart going back he's not going to get
it it's over his head
two runs will come in to score peru and
then
hernandez has kevin bizio drives in a
pair with an
opposite field of double so he got him
totter wells goes up the ladder strikes
richik out
but the blue jays do some damage against
jorge lopez
stewart one and two
that's it sharply by stewart out in the
right field his first hit
so he'll send up austin hayes
as hayes drives one to left field and
deep hernandez going back it's off the
wall
bro goes into second base they've got
hayes going back into the bag he's
safe one and two as a
better check this way joe west said no
he did it's a strikeout for murphy first
down of the inning
bouncing ball towards second simeon to
second for one map the first to double
play what a nice job by patrick murphy
there's a line drive in the center
pitcher coming on makes a nice diving
grab he's snow cone
and held on to it good play by grichik
to retire aureus
and we go to the top of the order for
ryan mckenna
it back up the middle it gets past the
dive of simeon there you go
trey mancini didn't start today and he
comes to the plate
the tying run is on base
bounce right back to the mound and mazer
will run it halfway to first and he gets
out of it orioles will go back to the
bullpen and his time calling dylan tate
he went around nasty slider
down and away really key piece and there
he strikes out the side
nasty stuff he goes hernandez springer
and bishop anthony castro making his
19th appearance of the season
breaking ball he drops it in there for a
strike and hayes is caught looking
swinging a miss he went with the slider
again and later strikes up
[Applause]
there's another good slider how about
castro he strikes out the side
in the eighth dylan tate who struck out
the side of the seventh inning is going
to stay on for the orioles
another strikeout faced four struck them
all out
somebody finally gets maguire it's dylan
tate he
faces six he strikes out five
jordan romano loosening up for his 29th
appearance of the season
and he's looking for his sixth save of
the seasons
came back with another slider a little
dribbler to the third nice play by
espinal
[Applause]
daddy guerrero begs it right in front of
the
orioles dug out two down now
swinging a miss and the blue jays win it
romana with the strikeout
he'll pick up the save the blue jays
witness series
three games to one five to two here on
sunday afternoon